[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to tonight's
episode of beginner breakdown my name is
Alex mullering and I'm excited to be
talking with you about our lesson today
uh the topic is honing your Tactical
radar and if you don't know what that
means we're going to get into it shortly
but the inspiration for this lesson
comes from a problem that I've
experienced a lot and I've talked about
with the chat before
um
the problem is puzzles I think puzzles
are an excellent way to improve your
skill at chess
they increase your pattern recognition
especially if you do them quickly and
kind of try and really quickly analyze
what's going on and if you take a longer
time with puzzles they improve your
visualization but the problem is that
whenever you go into a puzzle you know
there's a solution whereas when you're
playing in a normal chess game you don't
know if any given position has a right
answer
this happens even at the highest level
of play so this is actually taken from a
game of two players 20 300 2400 almost
caliber very very strong Masters
and in the game
white has a very easy win in this
position but white didn't find it white
played just very naturally trying to
stop this Pawn from promoting trying to
get ours to promote continued with King
D5 or I'm sorry not King B5 King D5
trying to slowly move the king in
because White had no outside knowledge
that this position could be solved the
game continued Bishop G1 King E6 Bishop
F2 King D7 trying to get the king closer
trying to force this King out of the
corner
black just continues to kind of play
Waiting moves Knight to E5 check with
the bishop again trying to find
something but unfortunately this move
allows black to escape
and a draw commenced black is pushing
this Pawn we have to take it or else
they will promote and it will be a draw
even with the extra piece it's not going
to be enough black is going to be able
to survive so
what white mist is in this position
there's actually a way to make progress
if you take a quick look at what's going
on and there may have been time pressure
going on in this game but we noticed
that Black's dark squared Bishop cannot
interact with any of our pieces at the
moment all of them are on the light
squares the second thing you notice is
that Black's King is stalemated if we
don't make any moves
our pawn and Knight control all of the
squares this King could go to
which means
if we can use this bishop to find a way
to win it's actually very simple Bishop
to H3
Bishop to C8 it doesn't matter that we
can't stop this Pawn
because this is Checkmate and there's
actually nothing that black could have
done to stop it this seems like such a
simple idea right just moving the bishop
around to get a Checkmate unfortunately
it was missed in the game and this is
not unique to this game this happens at
all levels of play but it is a problem
and so the idea I would like to present
is actually borrowed from a really good
book called tune your chest tactics
antenna not sponsored or anything by
Emmanuel Neiman definitely recommend it
and the idea is we are going to try and
find signals in these positions that
whenever we're playing a normal game of
chess you can see something in the
position that says oh that's off I
should take a closer look maybe there is
a tactic here
and he actually in the book gives seven
signals
the first one is King position second is
unprotected pieces third is alignment
fourth is night Fork distance five
trapped pieces six uh crucial or
overloaded Defender and six The
Defenders are too far away or I'm sorry
seven we're gonna go into all of those
one at a time
um starting with the most important uh
King position but before we do that I
want to kind of show an example game to
give you a sense of how we can use our
tactical radar so this was a game
between uh Larry Christensen and Anatoly
karpov again very high level players
and uh Christensen had white and he
began with D4 Knight to F6 C4 uh E6 we
have a nimzo Indian defense Knight to F3
B6 A3 and we'll kind of go through the
beginning of this game Queen to C2
Bishop B7 both players kind of
developing uh striking out into the
center
E4 Pawn takes Pawn Knight takes Pawn
uh the game continues and we reach this
position
uh black plays an interesting move here
Knight to H5 which is trying to
challenge this white Bishop uh
the unfortunate downside is it misplaces
the Knight for the moment but on its own
this move is fine uh the Knight doesn't
really belong here and it's not
protected but it does attack our Bishop
he drops it back to E3 not wanting to
trade and here karpov on move 11 makes a
blunder Bishop to D6 looking to activate
this piece likely hoping to maybe make a
battery or maybe more likely bring it
back to C7 to get out of the way of this
Pawn
um and be able to Castle the king
unfortunately this should already start
of provoking some signals in our
tactical radar so it's white to move
here and the signal that this one is
operating on is signal number two
uh We've looked at this position before
in this class
um
in previous beginner breakdowns but the
signal here is actually unprotected
pieces this Knight on H5 that attacked
our Bishop is not defended by anything
and this bishop that has just been
placed on D6 is not protected by
anything and even though karpov likely
just wants to quickly solve that problem
we get one move to deal with these two
unprotected pieces does anyone in the
chat or in our audience see what move
white should play here to gain an
advantage as always if you're watching
this uh on YouTube later feel free to
please pause the video and take as much
time with any of these positions as you
would like but it is white to move
anyone have any ideas here to uh to get
a winning advantage
and we have a lot of people in the chat
throwing the right move out there yes
totally correct
um noticing that these two pieces are
not defended if we can attack both of
them with a double attack we'll be good
we don't really have too many ways to
attack the Knight we could bring a
bishop to attack it on this diagonal or
perhaps Our Queen
we could use a pawn
with this bishop it's even harder we can
push some pawns or you know throw some
pieces away but our only very safe
attacks might involve our Knight or our
Queen on uh this file or a rook perhaps
but when we start to see that that this
line can attack this bishop on the file
we can attack the Knight on the diagonal
you can actually find Queen to D1
and in this position move 12 Anatoly
karpov champion of the game Legend
resigned because
one of these pieces is going to fall
there's nothing you can do to defend
them both
a single unprotected piece is already
enough reason to awaken your Tactical
radar it's seeing something in your
opponent's side that's unprotected can
signal to you that we should be looking
for something in the position
the fact that there were two here meant
that Christensen just took a second and
found it very quickly
in some positions you know there is a
solution in some there isn't it's hard
to know which is which but hopefully
these seven signals can give us a bit of
a hint
so let's jump to Signal number one king
position
the first of these signals is the most
important right because any attack
against the king could potentially uh
end the game with a win
um usually just one of these signals or
motifs on their own is not enough to
definitively end a game or even show
that we can force a win
but a wheat King on its own is enough in
some situations to just change the fate
of the game so anytime the king is weak
meaning we have things we can use to
attack it or it's exposed by pawns we
should already have our signal alerted
that maybe there's a tactic here
so
let's take a look at an example here
this game was gligric versus Rosenstein
and we have kind of an interesting
opening sort of a nimsovich defense with
Knight C6 not something you see very
often and here black plays F5
this is not like a mistake in any sense
but we should already be noticing an
open King means maybe there is a
potential for attack normally you want
to keep this F Pawn more reserved
because it can be used against a king so
already something to watch out for
the game continues uh for some time
uh both players just kind of making some
even trades like getting some space in
the center black fighting for it with
their Knight black putting their Queen
on the file to hopefully make some
discovered attack so we block it this is
an example of alignment which we'll get
to uh in a few examples
but both sides just continue to try and
fight and make progress
and we reach a fairly uh interesting
position
around this move
in this position it's White's move
and we can notice a few things one
White's doing better on space I would
say development blacks pieces are kind
of discoordinated they're not really
attacking too much and they're not
really defending too much either White's
pieces really occupy some nice Central
squares squares near the king we have
lots of threats so this is a very
pleasant position to play as white
but the thing that we want to emphasize
here is the king position so uh White
was just able to play this bishop H5
check and the King stepped out of the
way meaning castling is no longer
allowed
and queens are on the board so already
this king is going to have a bit of a
harder time stepping away
um
so keeping some of these things in mind
with the signal that the king is kind of
weak and we might be able to create some
attack does anyone see any ideas that
look promising
all right so someone in the chat
suggesting Knight E6 this makes sense
calling a check attacking a lot of
pieces
that seems reasonable
other suggestions
again in person or the chat is all
always welcome for comments
yeah and I kind of agree with pumpkin
the cat so Knight E6 I think looks
interesting the problem might be that
this Knight does act as a defender of
that square
so perhaps we can trade or try and break
into the position but we might be giving
up too much and when we are attacking
generally you want to avoid trades
because those pieces are going to help
you uh take care of the king unless you
see a forced solution
Queen to G4 also suggested placing the
queen a little more near the king I
think this is a reasonable idea as well
and there might be some Merit to it
although I do like the benefit of having
the queen and Rook kind of lined up
together
go ahead
okay what's your idea with taking the
bishop
yeah so you're I think seeing something
that's very critical in this position is
yeah so this is actually called the
Opera mate when you have the bishop and
The Rook working together so notice this
king's position
uh right now it's locked in by a bunch
of its own pieces and our Bishop the
only squares that aren't hit are the
king itself and this square right next
to it
which means if we can get a rook down
there we will achieve the Opera mate so
a rook or a queen or some piece that
attacks on a straight line uh would
destroy the king it would just be a
Checkmate if we could achieve it to help
visualize this a little more
Let's uh clear the board of some of
these kind of less relevant pieces
this is the core elements
everything is exactly the same we've
gotten rid of some of these defensive
pieces all of Black's undeveloped pieces
are still around they're not helping
but we have this very clear threat right
Rook to E8
if we can achieve this right this
harmony between our pieces we're going
to win because this king is too weak so
let's jump back into the game
this is our position now that we see
that we're actually able to find the
right move right we've received the
signal this position is strange and we
recognize one of the patterns uh the
Opera mate
and are able to bring it together so we
see the reasons we can't do this are
because one the queen defends the square
and two the bishop is in the way
but we have enough Firepower that we can
actually just forcibly remove them both
Queen takes E7
after the queen takes
you can play Rook takes Queen this is
also going to work even better here
is Bishop D6
the queen is now stuck and it's
deflected you cannot move it anywhere so
we're just going to take it with the
bishop or The Rook next move anyway and
still threaten this Checkmate the only
thing you can try is to take our Bishop
which allows our beautiful checkmate
and all of this we can find right if you
reach this position we can look at a lot
of candidate moves Knight to E6 Queen to
G4 but the these are the positions you
want to stop and slow down in right and
the First Signal you always look for is
the king position King safety it's just
so critical
let me give a few more kind of uh broken
down examples this one's a little more
complex
in this position it's white to move
and let's see if we can find the best
move for whites considering the king
position as a signal
okay
so a lot to take in with this position
it's a very imbalanced game
or I'm sorry it's very even the
imbalances we have two nights in a
bishop and black has two Bishops and a
knight but we are able to take advantage
and pumpkin the cat in the chat glad to
have you back has spotted the move this
king is exposed on this diagonal so even
though the king can presumably castle
and can even block this check any
opening any open Line whether it's a
file or a rank or a diagonal that we can
use to attack the king should always be
in consideration meaning that Queen to
B5 is going to be our winning move here
this couples with signal 2 of
unprotected pieces because this bishop
is unprotected and you can actually work
at it from that side too we have an
unpredicted piece oh we can attack it
here and that also is going to hit this
exposed King so a lot of these are going
to work together and when you see
multiple signals on your tactical radar
that really should get you to stop and
look at the position
um but yeah someone in the chat I don't
know if this is like a chess quote or
something you're saying but generally
speaking the presence of a weak King
often increases both the possibilities
and consequences of tactics I fully
agree that sounds like you're quoting if
you came up with that that's pretty
awesome but yeah so always keep an eye
out for an exposed King here
on any open lines
something else that can signify a weak
King is the inherent weakness of the F
Pawns in the starting position
I did a whole lecture on this I think
it's just called like
actually don't even remember
um but it's on the weaknesses of this
f-pawn uh so maybe I'll look into that
later
um there's a lot of lectures that I'm
going to be referring to here that I
recommend
um but these two pawns are so weak in
the starting position because they are
the only ones defended simply by the
King right every other Pawn has
something else defending it the F Pawn
is only defended by the king
because of that it's a really good
gateway to attacks so often you see
openings based around this you know
where we put a bishop on this line or
maybe a queen you can sometimes jump in
with a knight to attack here it's a very
common theme
and uh so one example of that would be
something like this let's look at a
Scandinavian
he takes D5 Queen takes D5 Knight to C3
Queen to d8
we're just going to do some normal
development but we're going to start
putting some pressure against this
Square
Bishop to C4
normal development but black has to be a
little bit careful Pawn to A6
looking to perhaps expand on the queen
side with B5 attacking our Bishop
Knight to E5
notice that this Pawn now is a serious
Target if you don't do something about
it if you continue with your plan of B5
or just play some other move Bishop
takes F7 is actually now just Checkmate
we control both of the king's Escape
squares and the bishop checks the king
so you have to stop that threat
something like E6
and there's a really nice trick here
Queen to E2 and let's say black does not
like our Knight being so close and they
play knight from B to D7 to try and
challenge our piece make some trades and
open up their position
noticing that we have a lot of pressure
against the king and against the F7
Square can anyone find the best move for
white in this position
okay Knight takes F7 with the idea that
after King takes
precisely we have undermined the defense
of this E6 pawn and our pieces are too
strong once the Knight is out of the way
we'll have a discovered attack
and this is going to inevitably lead to
the king's downfall
you don't have to take this Knight but
if you don't you're losing a bunch of
material
so to try and prove something King takes
the only move here is King to G6 and
with this King out now in the center of
the board it's going to be very very
tough to beat perhaps something like H4
looking to press forward with H5 and
just kind of eviscerate the King on this
diagonal very unfortunate spot to be in
for black
one possible line would be something
like H5 to prevent us from doing that
and then we can continue check
mates
alternatively if you don't do that if
you allow H5 perhaps you play Knights to
B6 to attack the queen this is not going
to help you anymore because we can now
play H5 and release our Bishop into the
game
this will also eventually result in a
checkmate
so keeping an eye out for weaknesses on
the F2 and F7 pawns especially in the
openings before our opponents have
castled always going to be helpful there
are similar motivic sacrifices against
H7 sometimes with Greek gifts and or H2
with fishing poles we've seen some of
these ideas before but always keep those
weaknesses around the king in mind in
addition to any open lines
and finally as kind of that last one
ended anytime the king is in the center
it's inherently weaker in this position
even though we are down a full piece as
black
white has this extra night because our
pieces are more developed and this king
is in the center we have a really
beautiful way to win uh the game here
it is white to move
and we looked at this last week so if
you want to take some time and look at
it feel free but quickly to help out the
problem white has is they don't want to
lose this queen the king needs to stay
defending it is black to move
um
but the problem is first we can take
this Pawn
if the king takes the queen is not
defended so the King has to move the
only way it can move to defend the queen
is to go to D5
and we can attack it again with our
Bishop
and finally with the rook and the king
is stuck and these tactics are not so
hard to find because the king is in the
center so being able to sometimes lure
the king out can also be a huge benefit
especially if Queens are off the board
but even if you're just in a really
active position so something to keep an
eye out for so keep this theme in mind
King position is going to be Central to
any tactic maybe not any there are
sometimes you can just win some material
but major tactics will always involve
the king
and definitely keep that in mind anytime
something seals off with the King
position that should be a signal for
your Tactical radar just take a second
stop do some more analysis and
calculation to try and find a winning
solution
uh the second signal is unprotected
pieces
so I'm going to segue into this one by
kind of using the theme of King safety
as well but the basic idea is an
unprotected piece or Square even
sometimes creates the possibility to
attack something in order for it to be a
signal though I want to be very clear it
has to be possible for us to actually
attack whatever that thing is so for
example in the starting position none of
these Rooks are defended
but neither side is in the position to
attack them so a rook just sitting
unprotected is not so helpful for a
position however
if after a few moves
someone opens up the ability to attack a
rook either in this case by trying to
take space on the queen side with an
attack or
um more often it will be because they've
tried to fiancado a bishop something
like this
anytime there is an exposed line to an
unprotected piece you should already be
looking out for tactics and then this
position
funny enough two moves in there is one
so it is uh White here to move and try
and find the best move
Bishop where okay Bishop F7 King takes
where
yeah so we are going to have our
thematic sacrifice against F7 to lure
the king out
because this Rook is so exposed and once
the king is out our Queen's going to
come and play our plan is to go to D5
so if you play something like G6 to
block
we Fork the king and the rook and we'll
pick up the unprotected piece uh an
exposed King just on an open line is
usually you should trade it about the
same as an unprotected piece because
it's a Target that we can attack and
then hopefully find some double attack
or fork with that if the king is more in
the center if there's other issues with
like the F Pawn that can be a more
profound weakness but simply an exposed
King can lead us to this if they try
anything to stop G like to stop our
Queen from going to D5 like something
crazy like King E6
one this doesn't actually stop us from
playing Queen D5 but worse with the king
in the center uh the king will be
quickly checkmated
uh same thing if they do king F6 we
control all of these squares
um I did a whole lecture on unprotected
pieces quite recently called loose
pieces drop off so for more on this
signal definitely check that one out on
YouTube I might even still be on Twitch
because I want to do a more kind of
comprehensive Overlook we're not going
to go too deep into any one of these
signals but I do recommend checking that
one out because unprotected pieces I
mean you're going to want a lot of
material if you start paying attention
to the unprotected pieces in the game
and being more cognizant of how to not
just leave yours weak to attacks
very quickly I will kind of diverge on
this one to one more example with an
untreated piece
that also goes back to our initial
discussion I also showed this example I
think last week
but this was a game featuring Gary
Kasparov with the black pieces and 10
moves into the game it was a very normal
opening
and his opponent was a 2700 right these
are like again some of the greatest
players who have ever played this game
and in this position
white decided to Castle
and black decided to Castle very normal
moves they thought they were playing a
chess game they didn't think they were
solving a puzzle
because in this position
this work is unprotected and there's an
open line to attack it and Bishop to E5
there's actually nothing but light can
do to save material here
it's so simple in 10 moves the the
greatest players of this game
um yes this was uh rustam uh Kaz
madisonov I don't know exactly how to
say the last name I apologize for that
mispronunciation uh but yeah uh Legends
of the game
uh did not see this really simple move
attacking an unpredictable piece because
probably one at that level they're
expecting their opponent not to make
such an easy blender or to miss one
themselves so they were probably just
thinking this is a normal chess game but
already there is uh opportunity so
always keep an eye for these signals
right it can really elevate your game
okay so that was the first signal and
the second Signal King position King
safety and then unprotected pieces the
third one is alignment and Alignment
we're just talking about pieces being in
the same line so whether that's your own
pieces whether it's like a doubled Rook
situation a battery of some kind or a
discovered attack waiting to happen
whether it's your opponents so maybe
there's a pin or a skewer involved I
mean a lot of these terms I'm throwing
out are some of the fundamental tactics
of chess pin skewers discovered attacks
right they all involve alignment pieces
occupying the same line whether that's a
rank a file or a diagonal so alignment
can be really important in these games
let's take a look
at this game this was Alexi Alexandra
versus Anatoly fossier in 2011.
and they had a pretty normal game we'll
kind of stop at a few moments we're not
going to spend too much time
but we're going to notice some themes
so very early on we have again kind of
this finchetto idea with B6
and um
fossier decides to give up this C Pawn
in order to get some extra development
activate these pieces notice the queen
and Bishop are on this nice battery so
alignments going on in this position
that we should be aware of if this
Knight moves there is a discovered
battery that could be a potential issue
Bishop to E2
game continues now the king is castled
so now if this Knight moves we have a
potential Checkmate so that's something
to really important to keep out this
Knight is pinned to this Square now if
it moved to H4 it would defend
but what would be wrong with Knight to
H4
we could remove that Defender yes Bishop
takes and then we would follow it up
with a Checkmate or save our Bishop
maybe there's some tricks they can play
with like this but again this is a
little we don't want to get too far off
this is not what happened in the game
something to keep an eye on though
Queen goes to B3 and now you're going to
notice in the next uh the long neck
sequence of moves is black and white are
kind of going to be fighting over this
open C file open files are very
important especially when you can get
your Rooks and heavy pieces on there to
try and invade into the seventh Rank and
black is ultimately going to win this
battle for the C file
slowly but surely moving and improving
their position again tarp creating
batteries to line up their pieces for
potential attacks
lining up the Rooks to get total control
over this file and you can see that
White's position is already looking a
little more passive and black is being
very active lots of threats lots of
potential with their pieces lined up
and we're going to continue a few more
moves in
and we get to this position
and uh in this position already even
though white is still up the pawn from
earlier black has managed to use that to
gain a really strong grip on the C file
and white makes a slip up Queen to F2
and we can notice a really big problem
in White's position because of that move
considering our issue of alignment right
tactical signals it might not be obvious
at first
but the Queen and King are now lined up
anytime something like that happens
because there's always the potential for
Pins or skewers a king being in the line
with anything you should always be
considering pins always be considering
sacrifices to open that up because if we
can get some kind of pin on the queen
and the King this is going to be
excellent for us and actually there's
too many issues of alignment here Rook
C2 I don't believe will work I'm not
sure exactly what you're seeing but the
problem here I think is we only have one
defender of that rook and white will
have two attackers so it's a nice idea
but white has managed to keep us from
infiltrating the second rank
however we do have another tactic so
does anyone see the best move here for
black
uh
uh D4 you mean or yeah yeah Rook takes
D4 no you're good you're good um Rook
takes D4 and a lot of people in the chat
seeing it as well and white has two
problems one
if they don't take back if they don't
take this Rook
then we have lined up our Queen and Rook
on the D file now we've switched from C
to the D file and opened it up this
Knight is in big trouble it can't move
because it is pinned and this Rook will
fall this Rook is only defended once but
it would be attacked twice
and if you don't move the Knight it's
attacked three times so this night will
fall or The Rook will fall if you don't
take
so you take
and now Bishop takes D4
and in this position White's Queen is
lost I believe the game continued for a
couple more moves but uh it was pretty
fruitless and white eventually resigns
alignment is an incredibly powerful tool
whether it's your own pieces being in a
line working together to infiltrate or
your opponents being in a line and being
able to exploit that so keep an eye for
alignment in the games as well another
example here
not a super long game but there are some
complications and we're going to jump
ahead this is a game
um again I'm going to mispronounce this
name between Ahmed samhori and Judith
Polgar the legendary women's grand
master champion incredible player
um and we reached this position White's
last move was F4 and uh Polgar has the
black pieces
this is a fairly complicated position
but let's try and break it down
starting simply with the alignments so
looking at this position what are the
relevant alignments you can see that we
should be paying attention to
again that means pieces of our own that
are lined up pieces that of our
opponents that are lined up
Etc
okay first one is very clear the Knight
is pinned to the king Our Queen is
occupying this line uh so that is seems
probably the most obvious the most
relevant so I want to keep that in mind
pin pieces don't protect we also want to
attack them when possible because they
can't move out of the way so Knight is
pinned what else what are some other
alignments that might be important in
this position
yeah so uh another one here someone in
the chat as well saying a few people is
uh these Bishops are kind of weirdly
lined up on the C file and our Rook also
is starting to have a grip perhaps we
can double the Rooks perhaps we can make
some moves in towards the C file against
these Bishops especially considering
that this bishop is only defended by the
queen because this Knight again is
pinned it's not actually defending okay
so C file seems relevant potentially for
some alignment issues
uh oh and
calibrated mudok I don't know if I'm
saying your name right as well notices
that this bishop is aligned through E4
against this one so again not exactly a
pin but if this Pawn were to move I
guess it could be a pin if this Pawn
were to move we would now have multiple
attackers okay so maybe now the C file
and our Bishop are coordinated
okay so that's also good to notice
the last one is actually the hardest to
see uh so I'm going to help you with the
last one but I think these are some
really good ones to notice and the last
one is kind of the the piece day
resistance
is the semi-open E file we do not have a
Pawn on this file and even though it is
very clogged this Rook is about to have
a lot of fun on this file
with all of that in mind
we can start to try and do some
calculations and piece together and find
the best move if you want to take a
second and try and find it that's
totally fine this is a very hard
position and I would not expect you to
to get the move but just seeing the
signals that we should start looking is
already more than enough
um the best move here the move that
Polgar found in the game was Knight to
D5
it kind of incredible move not taking
anything putting a knight in direct
Harm's Way of the pawn but this move
Reveals All of the Fatal flaws we are
both of our Knights are attacked by
pawns
um however there's too many alignment
issues and we're about to see why
uh in the game e takes D5
seems very reasonable
but this now opens up our pinned bishop
or sorry the pinned Pawn against the
bishop Bishop takes C2 Queen has to move
Queen goes to E2
and now we have Knight to D3
invading attacking this Rook trying to
undermine uh the defense of this Knight
and slowly but surely clearing the E
file for our Rook to join The Fray and
get involved
this is a very dangerous position I
believe in the game
Knight to F3 was played
adding the bishop as a Defender to the
Knight but this also does not work as
Knight takes F4
attacking the queen
Queen to H2
Knight back to D3 attacking The Rook
eventually we're either just going to
take this Rook or it's going to move and
we now control this entire file our
Bishop will move somewhere we will have
total control and the game will be over
if right away you try to move the Rook
so an after Knight to D3 you try and
save The Rook something like Rook to F1
then you can continue here with Bishop
to H4
opening up The Rook
and there's not really anything to do
Rook to F3 defending but Knight takes F4
still attacks the queen if you take we
can take uh
this this Knight and the position is
just falling apart again it's a pretty
complex one but just understanding the
issues of these alignments can help us
start to see that we need to take a
closer look
okay so first three signals King
position
King safety in general second one is
unprotected pieces third one is
alignment so if you see any of these
things in a position you should already
be thinking there might be a tactic here
if you see multiple of them you
absolutely should be thinking there
might be a tactic here
signal number four is night Fork
distance so this one might seem pretty
obvious but if you see pieces in a
position that are
able to be simultaneously attacked by
one Knight this is really useful
a fork is just any double attack that's
carried out by a knight or a pawn
but upon Fork always involves alignment
right we can imagine if this Pawn were
to Fork two of our pieces
they would have to be here they would
always by definition occupy the same
rank so again another reason to look out
for alignment so we're not going to talk
as much about Pawn Forks but night Forks
are really weird because Knights move
differently than all the other pieces
they don't go in a straight line and so
we should always be kind of keeping a
look out one thing that I have is kind
of a quick advice with the Knights is
one a knight always is going to move to
a different color square but if you're
looking for somewhere it can go to Fork
you want to make sure the pieces are the
same color so let's see if we can find
the fork in this example
it's white to move and find the best
idea and there's actually kind of two in
this one it's kind of sneaky
um yeah pumpkin the cat with the right
idea I don't actually think it matters
but yeah white to move what should we do
here
uh yeah one of these nights to uh D6 I
actually yeah I don't think it matters
which one because it's a check I would
probably move this one just because it's
under attack seems a little safer to me
but the idea is okay what's the point
you call check sure but I'll just move
my king
so what's your follow-up
you have the right idea
what is the benefit of getting a knight
to this Square
so we get track the king is a little
exposed but also
notice that these two Rooks are Fork
distance
because they are both on the same color
and then we can quickly see oh if I
could get a knight on F7 I would hit
both of these Rooks well
we can do that so our first Fork is
actually between F7 and this King
we're going to force our way into F7
with one of these two knights if you
take us I just retake it doesn't help if
I move it doesn't change anything either
eventually a knight will make its way
to F7 forking these two pieces
so uh yeah really keep an eye out for
these night Forks one more fun example
of this signal is this position which is
from a game that was in the 1969 Soviet
championship between Mikhail Tao and
cherepcov
really really fun one always fun to see
some tile tactics so white to move see
if you can find the way that tal managed
to turn this game from a totally even
position into a winning one
uh yeah what's the follow-up
so keeping an eye on our Fork distance
we can see that this queen
is actually Fork distance from this
night now it being a fork distance from
a knight isn't so helpful because the
Knight is the one piece you can't fork
with another night at least not really
effectively
however we can actually deflect the king
force it to move where we want and now
we will pick up
the queen
so this is a really nice position
um kind of again articulating some of
the benefits of seeing this kind of fork
distance if you see two pieces that if
you had a knight you could drop on a
square it would be a fork that's a
signal right May if you don't have any
knights in the position then that's a
signal that doesn't matter but it's at
least something that should kind of pop
your eye and again for this one uh
there's I didn't spend a whole lecture
on night Forks but I did one talking
just about the night called the Knight's
Tale so feel free to check that out it
does give some more examples on these
types of forks and ways you can look for
them
that's one through four signal number
five is the trapped piece this is
actually a really cool position that was
a study by uh Alexi troytsky I believe
in 1924. so I don't believe this was
from a game it looks like a composition
um but it's really kind of fun
and the idea is this for our signal
number five trapped pieces uh they exist
because in the game of chess like a lot
of board games we have a limited number
of squares so domination which is
another theme domination is the idea
where you would just attack something
and it has no available place to run
away is incredibly important right it's
probably the most important theme
because when it's in the context of a
king it's a Checkmate right if you take
away all the squares from an opponent's
king you've dominated that King you win
the game but we can apply this to other
pieces as well
and in this position notice that black
is pretty stuck here because this bishop
right now can't move back if it moves
forwards we're going to take it this
Pawn has no moves and this King does not
have a lot of options so the best move
here is actually to play King H6
the idea is now if this bishop moves
anywhere we take it and if this King
moves anywhere except h8 we take the
bishop and we're going to win this game
uh so you have to play King to h8
and we're basically going to do this fun
little Loop to Loop Knight to H4
King to G8 now we can't take this Pawn
even if our King was here we couldn't
take the pawn because uh they would be
able to take opposition and not we can't
win if they can stop our King from
making forward progress
um but quickly the reason you have to
play King to G8 here is because if you
drop the bishop back the king is now
stuck and this is a check mates
so instead King to G8
and we can slowly maneuver the Knight
where we want it to go King has to go
back we again threaten to go to G3 or
sorry to G6 if they drop back so the
King has to move again
back to D7
we go here and now there's two problems
if you move the bishop it's the same
Checkmate and if you move the king we
take the bishop
this one now we will be able to win with
our extra night we'll take this pawn and
promote and it's a really kind of fun
position uh illustrating that this the
the how we can exploit the fact that
this bishop is trapped
um
there's two basic types of trapping uh
in the first type the piece just doesn't
have any more squares to escape to and
it's going to be taken so that's this
example right this bishop doesn't have
anywhere to go and eventually we can
exploit that fact to capture it the
second type of trap just means that the
piece is so locked down and inactive
that it can't influence the game in any
meaningful way so we're going to look
kind of quickly at one example of each
with two of my favorite games the first
one is going to be this first type of
trapping where the piece is going to be
trapped and taken
uh this game I will tell you the name of
it in a moment I think I've shown it on
stream before but it's one of my
favorite games it's very quick
E4 E5 Knight F3 D6 so we have a
Philadelphia fence Bishop C4
Bishop E7 D4
some normal play capturing developing
Knight to F6 Knight C3 Knight C6 castle
castle H3
again nothing here is going to look too
weird until we get to this position
where black plays the slightly unusual
move Knight to D7
idea is probably to reroute the Knight
to B6 and attack our Bishop but it's
unusual because one it's kind of
undeveloping this piece we've already
gotten involved in the game and two it
is uh kind of cutting off this bishop so
our Bishop is a little worse now for one
move
which in most cases
probably wouldn't matter
but in this case it matters a lot
what is the trapped piece in this
position
what has black unwittingly trapped with
their last move
foreign
because it's not the bishop the bishop
is stuck
but that's very quickly going to be
solved
yeah in the chat they see their problem
this queen this very valuable Queen is
stuck in the spot
do we have any way to attack it well we
could play something like Knights takes
Knight or Knight take or Knight to E6
but in both cases we're going to be
covered
so how can we solve that problem
white to move and find the winning
sequence
um so Bishop takes on F7 okay uh
um could block though
um
yeah it didn't think about that that's
okay so it's a good thought so Bishop
takes King takes Queen F3 probably the
Knight will block there's actually so
this is really funny
um this is going to tie it back into
King position as well right because we
have these threats on F7 and we're going
to try and lure this King out
Bishop takes F7 is correct if the king
just moves somewhere then it doesn't
matter we play this move and win the
queen so the King has to take
we have a better move than Queen F3
that's pretty hard what do you think
Queen H5 also looks tempting
um if Queen H5
maybe G6 and then I still have this idea
of blocking if you come back and attack
on F3
so Creative Travel looks tempting uh
this is really funny
the move here and this game is called
the smothered Queen game
is Knight to E6 anyway
because if the king is lured out this
far into the center we have now signals
of King position
if you don't take you lose the queen
it's trapped
and now
the bishop is stuck
the king is lost
really beautiful game really quick game
super fun
um and it's because of just one move
right it's so simple it's so elegant and
it's we're lucky that in this game uh
our opponent with the black pieces made
an unusual move and our opponent with
the white pieces was uh smart enough to
catch it and say that you have trapped
in too many of your pieces we're going
to be able to capture something or force
you to lure your king out into a
two-week position
so again always keeping these signals in
mind and adding them together the second
example of trap piece was where a piece
uh isn't able to be captured
in this one it sort of will be but it
isn't able to be captured it's just not
a part of the game it's not meaningful
anymore
uh and this is another really fun
example
uh kind of another one of these Immortal
games that I will tell you the name of
in a moment in this position it's black
to move see if you can find the best
move here using some of the signals that
we have
again we have a lot of them we have King
position we have unpredicted pieces
alignments uh we have Night Fork
distance and now we're on Signal five
trapped pieces so what looks like a
really good move here for black
uh to wear
yeah because uh this is a really good
move
we are threatening Checkmate right this
Rook is pinned it can't take us because
of alignment right so another signal and
the King position is very weak
so white has to do something about this
they can call check if they want but we
can just hide
um So eventually they will have to play
Queen to H3 defending
and now how can we trap the queen
Pawn to G4 this is called the tomb game
because the queen has to move we are
defending here
H5
these pawns can't move this queen can't
move this Rook can't move because it's
pinned this Knight could move
I'll just take it
or it could go here I'll just take it it
doesn't matter
so white doesn't really have any moves
so I played the move B4
and black played the move Rook to F1
now that I just legally can't move so
this piece can't move this piece can't
move the king is totally smothered the
queen has one legal move but it gets
taken by a pawn
and this is the swan
black for the rest of the game dawdled
The King
forced white to push all of their Pawns
and in this position White had to play
the only legal move Queen to H3
Pawn takes and there is no way to stop
Queen takes on G2 Checkmate uh
hilarious and beautiful game
um
and it illustrates how powerful trapping
an opponent's piece can be or noticing
if they have a piece that's misplaced
and is not going to be a part of the
game we can really abuse that now this
is again the extreme example but
hopefully that can signal to us that
something is going on in this case
after we're able to trap the queen
um
The Motif or the theme we're able to
find is a zuk Swang that these pieces
can't move because they're all trapped
and again those themes are going to be
very varied uh so you'll have to look
out for pin skewers checks discover
checks double checks Forks all of these
but hopefully this can signal you to
start looking for something
Okay so we've gotten through five
signals we've got two left and about
seven minutes can we do it I don't know
but we're going to try signal six is a
crucial defender or an overloaded
Defender so identifying these really
pivotal pieces in our opponent's Camp
um and again these are all starting to
blend together so you're going to see
all of the themes being relevant in a
lot of examples
sometimes your attacks or your opponents
or attacks are going to be kept at Bay
by just one piece like there's one thing
holding the entire Army together and if
we can identify what that is and remove
it or deflect it away then we can
sometimes win a lot of material or
sometimes even the game
in this example we would love to play
the move Queen to C3 lining up with our
Bishop alignment aiming at our
opponent's king king position because
this bishop is pinning this Pawn this is
almost a forced way to win what is the
problem with Queen to C3
there's one problem
why is black not lost in this position
block with the bishop yeah you cannot
play F6 because this Pawn is pinned so
Bishop to E5 the bishop is the key
Defender
once we have identified it get rid of it
Rook takes D6
after Queen takes
now
this game is over
um you can stop Checkmate but in order
to do it you have to give up one of
these pieces
white is up uh we we have the bishop
pair versus a knight this should be an
easy win
all because we spotted this crucial
Defender and we're able to sacrifice The
Exchange in order to win more material
back for it
here's another example
in this position it's white to move
what are the moves we would love to play
here and what is the problem
because I can see the move I would
really like to play I would love to play
the move Queen takes H7
uh checkmate
but there's a queen defending that
square
so what can we do how can we remove that
crucial Defender
Rook f8 another checkmate
Queen takes and we take here there's no
way for the queen who is overloaded and
overworked to defend against both
threats
Queen f8 would be nice but we just don't
have quite enough Firepower left
um yeah so again if you see a one piece
that is just holding everything together
or defending too many critical squares
we can sometimes use that to our
advantage and it should be a signal to
us that we should take a closer look and
see if we can find the right theme
whether it's removing the guard or
deflection or undermining or a pin right
so whatever the theme is that's going to
help us win
identifying the signal that tells us
there's something to look at in this
position is really critical
one more example here
of an overloaded Defender we have a lot
of threats against black in this
position right we have threats against
F7
with our Queen and Knight working
together but unfortunately the queen
stops those threats
and we have threats against D5
attacking as well but the queen stops
those threats
so how can we
stop the queen from being such a good
Defender
any ideas
yeah a few people in the chat are seeing
the right idea Rook E7
sacrificing The Rook so many pieces can
take it the problem is if uh yeah The
Rook shout out to Levy Rosman
um if either of these pieces take
then they block
and now our Queen is hitting here right
the queen no longer is defending
if you don't take my Rook blocks
so I've still cut off the queen and if
the queen takes you have let go of D5
and you will have to block and you will
be checkmated very quickly
so again spotting one piece that is
holding a lot of different parts of the
position together in these examples it
was all about the king sometimes it can
win you material but keeping an eye out
for those types of positions is again
going to be a signal to you to look a
little bit closer
the last signal with just a few minutes
remaining
is the defense being too far away
defense is not able to help it's not
really a good word for this
um but essentially an important Motif
lies in the inability of a defender or a
series of them to stop an attack usually
because they're on the wrong side of the
board or they're blocked off by pawns or
for whatever reason they're too far away
from the relevant area of the board
one common reason for this is
development so I believe in this game
if I'm not mistaken this bishop is the
one you want to keep an eye on because
it is not going to get developed
we have a long game here
where this bishop is just sticking
around on C8 everything else is kind of
getting involved
and black even spent some extra time
moving the Knight around moving the
queen around trying to make some attack
happen
and actually this game totally comes
down to the fact again you can see
they're kind of jumping the queen around
but this bishop is just never involved
which means because this wasn't
developed it's a compounding problem
these Rooks can't connect to each other
they're not neither of them are
defending each other it's harder for
them to get involved this queen and
Bishop are now kind of just totally away
and we have a lot of pieces at our
disposal for this attack our Bishop Our
Queen our Rook maybe our Knight this
Pawn can get involved
so because uh Black's Defenders are
undeveloped are disconnected and are too
far away from the relevant areas we have
a winning attack here
again it's a little hard to see if you
want to pause and find out take a look
but a few people in the chat already see
it Bishop to F6 pinning the pawn
threatening checkmate
if you take the bishop then Pawn takes
these pieces are too far away they can't
get involved we're going to get
checkmate if you block here
this forecast to defend too many squares
I will check my ung7 very quickly if you
play Rook to G8 right away this also
doesn't work due to some nice
sacrificial ideas again this Rook is now
also an overloaded Defender our sixth
signal
takes track brutal
so that is about all the time we have
um if you want I'll give you this last
position for for homework feel free to
pause it
um
white played the move F3 in this
position and because the defense was too
far away black was able to find a very
good win so feel free to solve this if
you want to put it in the chat as
suggestions or stick around after the
class and try and solve it that's fine
but I do thank you all for coming keep
these signals in mind in your chess
games hopefully they will help improve
your Tactical radar for when you see a
position you can know which ones to look
closer at and which not right King
position unprotected pieces trapped
pieces alignment crucial or overloaded
Defender and the defense being too far
away all can help us in our games thank
you so much please stick around for our
grand Masters lecture with Grandmaster
Josh Shang I believe right after this
and I hope to see you again soon
take care
[Music]